up to 100,000 people are being ordered
to evacuate in Bali where a massive
volcano is on the verge of a major
eruption mount a goon and eastern Bali
started spilling dark grey ash over the
weekend stretched about 20,000 feet into
the air tunisian officials raised the
volcano's alert status to its highest
level yet people within six miles of the
volcano were told to leave the area four
hundred and forty five flights were
cancelled at volleys International
Airport is ash filled the sky around
fifty nine thousand travelers were
stranded officials sent 100 buses to the
airport and ferry terminals to pick up
the stranded passengers nearly 5 million
tourists visited Bali last year
chief weather caster Lonnie Quinn of our
New York station WCBS is here with the
volcanoes impact
Lonnie good morning well good morning
everybody you know the key to what could
happen at Mount Agung is understanding
what's going on underneath mount a gun
now since its last eruption back in 1963
molten rock has been building up and
that molten rock generates a lot of heat
within a confined space which generates
a lot of pressure and that pressure has
now pushed the magma into the main vent
of the volcano and the eruption will
happen when that pressure just gets so
great that the magma is forced to blow
out the top of the volcano and a little
over two months ago the threat level for
an eruption was raised and 140,000
people have been evacuated a couple of
reasons for that number one big increase
in earthquakes around the volcano number
two the pressure has actually gotten so
great inside this volcano that the sides
are starting to bulge and so far there
have only been steam-based eruptions but
this volcano is moving into its most
dangerous phase the magmatic eruptions
phase which is of course lava but
besides lava a huge fat threat will be
pyroclastic flow that's a mixture of
steam and ash and rock and searing dust
and what makes it so dangerous it moves
a heck of a lot faster than lava 450
miles an hour down the side of the
volcano with temperatures at 1,800
degrees and they go from miles the last
eruption that pyroclastic flow stretched
eight miles from the crater but you want
to talk really big distances just think
about this the last time it erupted the
aerosols dropped global temperatures by
almost half a degree so even though we
are boy we're 10,000 miles or so from
the volcano
could still possibly have an infect an
impact on us Nora right here
Wow Lonnie that's a great explanation
thank you so much